the Old Forge was named Britain's most
remote pub by the Guinness Book of World
Records it's located here in Noida
northern Scotland nearly everyone who
tries to get there dies in that place ok
this isn't Mordor but it is tricky as we
found out one does not simply walk to
the Old Forge pub plan one we take the
train isn't that the train from Harry
pulse' oh it is so we pack our gear jump
on the train enjoy the breathtaking
scenery arrived at the Old Forge order a
pint and no no it doesn't work the train
doesn't come to know dirt it hands in
Malik terminal
hey wait who is this guy my name is JP
Robin and I'm the remotest publican in
mainland Britain oh ok
plan to we'll walk he's the plan we pack
our gear fill up our water bottles and
pack some snacks prepare for the
Scottish wilderness enjoy the
breathtaking scenery arrive at the Old
Forge order a pint and well you could
but to be honest I don't think you would
because at the 18 miles high and it's
very buggy no tracks just cross country
through the Highlands and you could
carry all your gears all the way up I
don't know it's quite difficult it's two
days hike one night in the Buffy okay
plan three we drive we pack up our gear
we Haruka
[Music]
make it a 4x4 and hit the road
enjoy the breathtaking scenery arrive at
the Old Forge order a pint and it's
totally impossible to drive here the
nearest road is 18 miles from here so
you need to park in Molly and jump on a
boat full time I would say around
hundred and thirty people live on the
peninsula of course the tourism is the
main part of our business we're really
busy between the 1st of March and
mid-october we've got the backpackers
and hikers because we're on one of the
two best hike in Scotland here here is
totally unspoiled no doubt is clearly
the last British wilderness ok final
plan we take the ferry we pack our game
buy a ticket get on the ferry enjoy the
breathtaking scene with my god there are
three whales right next to the boat
arrive Android art wave goodbye to the
ferry captain arrive at the Old Forge
order a pint M
you
[Music]